las manifestaciones contra Dina boluarte
se agudizan en Lima Los Fuertes
enfrentamientos de este sábado dejaron
muerto según informó la defensoría del
pueblo
lamentamos el fallecimiento de Víctor
Santi Esteban jacksabilca en las
manifestaciones violentas de hoy la
jefatura de guardia del hospital de
emergencias grau coordina con la
fiscalía para las diligencias de acuerdo
a la ley los disturbios iniciaron cuando
los manifestantes lanzaron objetos
contra la policía que respondió con
gases lacrimógenos y perdigones los que
asisten masivamente a las protestas son
acusados por el gobierno de terroristas
algo que ellos niegan
con sangre inca mi papi Don
terrorista como ellos dicen no soy no
soy delincuente yo trabajo formalmente
señores por favor Cómo ves Mira cómo nos
tiene por favor los manifestantes se
lanzaron inicialmente a las calles al
sur del país en una de las regiones más
pobres y marginadas de Perú causando
bloqueos que ocasionan escasez de
productos como gas de uso doméstico
alimentos y medicinas las protestas
antigubernamentales que iniciaron el 7
de diciembre cuando boluarte llegó al
cargo tras la destitución de Pedro
Castillo se extienden por Perú con el
paso de los días los manifestantes piden
que Dina boluarte renuncie se llame a
nuevas elecciones Y se cree una asamblea
Constituyente
boluarte visual congreso para que se
adelantaran los comicios para diciembre
de 2023 pero el legislativo rechazó la
iniciativa esta respuesta Aviva la
crisis que por el momento parece no
tener un próximo final
[Aplausos]